This person sent in this question and they called me back and said, I followed the answer to my questions
You don't have to put it in but I thought it was a good question to put in because this is really a hot topic
Um, in Instagram now I personally deleted my Instagram. We have our business Instagram account
So if you're following us here still see our Instagram posts that
My daughter is posting on there
For me, but I by personal Instagram
When I got this cold a few weeks ago, I was really praying and convicted by the Holy Spirit to not be looking at Instagram anymore
So I deleted Instagram and Facebook off my phone and I'm just gonna just spending my time reading my Bible
Eliciting to my Bible on tape when I have free time. That's just what the Holy Spirit has led me to do
but
You know if you listen to any that I've said in the last year to half that I have a really
Hard time with all these influencers on Instagram selling things
Because 90% of what they're selling a 10% of what they're selling they might be right on what they're saying and I agree with them
But 90% of the time I'm like oh my gosh are you kidding?
It's just ridiculous and I even though I do think red light therapy has benefits
I think it's a hundred percent oversold by influencers who are trying to sell red light therapy devices
So um red light therapy is a frequency of red light that is one the frequency and
It isn't powerful enough
As far as amp output an any red light therapy device to go any farther than the first layer of dermis of your skin
Now that being said, it can have benefits to helping you know heal the skin
It can have benefits to helping heal um
You know an infection or something on the skin
So I'm not saying there isn't a use for it. I'm just saying that
The influencers that are selling it are selling
Our making claims that could not be backed by science
And you know if they were a practitioner like me with a clinic
They would have the FDA after them and they would have
You know the state boards after them
For making claims that can't be backed by science
But it seems like as an influencer on Instagram and Facebook they could say anything they want to say and that bothers me a lot
I think that hurts the general public a lot and I think it hurts alternative care a lot
Because people get confused
Now that being said let me get to the question
I am seeing a lot of interesting information on the use of red light therapy for healing
And other uses such as cancer. I have an older led technologies LLC
DPL unit I purchased years ago and would consider using it
To assist in wood healing where the tumor is so if you have an external wound
And again, you're you're you're not expecting this red light therapy to go any deeper than a millimeter
And my all means yes, I think you can use it. I don't think there's any negatives to it
so
Continue with the question. I've seen both positive and negative opinions regarding the effects on a tumor
Would this be advantageous to getting direct as getting direct sunlight in warmer weather months
Thanks in advance for your insight
Um, I think getting direct sunlight would probably be better
But I think during the winter if you have a unit, there's nothing wrong with using it
Probably a lot of you that are listening to me have a red light therapy and you're using it
And you might feel like it's helped you by all means. I have no trouble using it
I have trouble with the claims that are being made about it trying to sell devices. That's my struggle with it
And that's my struggle with a lot of the different
therapies and or
Supplements that are being touted on the internet by influencers
It's the claims that are being made that can influence people in I think the wrong way